In the next few minutes, I'm going to throw a couple more vocabulary words into
our mix. First I want to talk about a special kind of expression. In fact,
the kind that we've seen most up to this time.
These are polynomials. A polynomial is an expression, made up of constants,
variables, or both, that are combined using addition, subtraction, or
multiplication. So this basically means that we have one or
more terms, like we've talked about before, added together.
The variables in a polynomial also have to have non-negative integer exponents.
So as an example of a polynomial, we might have something like 5 x cubed minus
one-half x y plus 7. Or maybe z plus 6 z squared, minus 7 plus 9 x cubed,
plus 8 x to the 5th. So, some polynomials that we see will have more than one
variable in them, like these two right here. But often times, we'll also see
polynomials that have just one variable involved, or maybe even none. So,
an example of that might be something like 4 n cubed plus 3 n squared plus 1.
But again, any combination of constants in variables using these operators, and
only these kind of exponents, makes a polynomial.